ความสำคัญของ quantum computing นั้นทั้งถูกประเมินต่ำเกินไป
และถูกพูดเกินจริงอย่างสุดขีดในเวลาเดียวกัน
แม้ว่ามันจะไม่ได้มาแทนที่คอมพิวเตอร์ทั่วไป
แต่นวัตกรรม quantum แสดงถึงกระบวนทัศน์การคำนวณใหม่
quantum computer สามารถทำงานร่วมกับการคำนวณปัจจุบัน
โครงสร้างพื้นฐานเพื่อแก้ปัญหาซับซ้อนที่ก่อนหน้านี้
ถือว่าไม่สามารถทำได้จริงหรือเป็นไปไม่ได้
สิ่งนี้อาจเปลี่ยนกระบวนทัศน์ได้อย่างสิ้นเชิง
ตัวอย่างเช่น ความยากในการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนขนาดใหญ่
เป็นจำนวนเฉพาะเป็นพื้นฐานของการเข้ารหัสสมัยใหม่
สำหรับขนาดตัวเลขที่ใช้ในการเข้ารหัส public
private key สมัยใหม่ การคำนวณนี้จะต้องใช้เวลา
กับคอมพิวเตอร์ทั่วไปที่เร็วที่สุดกว่า 300 ล้านล้านปี
สำหรับ quantum computer ขนาดใหญ่ที่ทำงาน
ด้วย Shor's algorithm การคำนวณนี้อาจใช้เวลาเพียงไม่กี่วินาที
ปัญหาซับซ้อนแบบนี้มีอยู่ในทุกอุตสาหกรรม
แอปพลิเคชันที่เป็นไปได้สำหรับ quantum computing
นั้นกว้างขวางมาก
quantum computer กำลังเติบโตใหญ่ขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
และมีความสามารถมากขึ้น
เมื่อเรามุ่งแก้ปัญหาที่ซับซ้อนยิ่งขึ้น
ตั้งแต่ปี 2016 IBM ทำให้ quantum computer เข้าถึงได้
สำหรับสาธารณชนผ่านเว็บไซต์ที่มีอินเทอร์เฟซแบบกราฟิก
ที่ดูเหมือนโน้ตเพลง
และ software development kit Qiskit
ที่ให้ผู้ใช้โปรแกรม quantum computer ได้
นักวิทยาศาสตร์ทั้งในและนอกโลกองค์กร
กำลังรันการทดลอง
ผ่านพอร์ทัลที่คล้ายกัน พวกเขาสำรวจแนวทางด้านเคมี
และปัญหา machine learning เพื่อหาคำตอบว่า
จะถามคำถามแบบไหนได้บ้าง
และจะตั้งกรอบคำถามเหล่านั้นอย่างไร
เมื่อเทคโนโลยีพัฒนาไปอีก ตอนนี้คือ
เวลาที่เหมาะสมสำหรับผู้นำธุรกิจที่จะเตรียมพร้อม
สำหรับ quantum สภาวะพร้อมแล้วสำหรับการทดลอง
และขยายเทคโนโลยีใหม่พื้นฐานนี้
องค์กรที่ต้องการอยู่แถวหน้า
ของการเปลี่ยนแปลงครั้งสำคัญนี้จะ
คว้าความได้เปรียบในการแข่งขัน การฝึกอบรมนี้
จะเตรียมความพร้อมให้คุณเริ่มต้นการเดินทาง quantum!